[Music]
so the administration is yammering a lot
this week about gun control they're
taking your assault weapons you have to
submit to a background check if you want
to give your boy a 22 for christmas
etcetera etcetera so with that in mind
fascinating story in politico today
2018 hunter biden joe biden private
citizens they don't have secret service
protection
hunter biden gets in some kind of
dispute with his girlfriend who's also
the current president's daughter-in-law
a very complicated story
but she takes his 38 revolver and throws
it away
big kerfuffle about where it is delaware
police begin investigating and then the
secret service which does not work for
the bidens gets involved and goes to the
gun shop where hunter biden bought the
gun and demanded the gunshop owner turn
over paperwork related to the sale of
the weapon
he goes no you've got nothing to do with
this i'm not giving you the paperwork
they were trying to take it apparently
corruption but here's the most
interesting part politico obtained the
firearms transaction record and a
receipt for the gun
and hunter biden responded no if you
ever filled out one of these forms you
know a lot of questions have you done
this have you done that
hunter biden was asked as all gun buyers
are are you addicted to or a user of
unlawful substances well of course he
was even booted out of the navy for it
everyone knew it he lied about it
that's a felony you try that on a
federal gun form you'd be in jail right
now just like chewbacca guy
hunter biden book contract from simon
schuster couple million bucks
weird how that works